what's up I'm Kiana of the day my album
grudges is coming out on June 16th and
I'm here at the boulay Kev podcast
show special guest in here from Phoenix
Arizona
hey hey well first of all it's nice to
finally like get up with you I've been
talking to Davey I'm like bro you guys
got this girl she's from my hometown
she's like the only person popping we
gotta talk
I'm really excited to be here so what uh
part of Phoenix are you from Seventh and
Baseline seventh oh you're from the
South Side um I like my best friend
lived on 24th Street and Baseline when I
was a kid so I spent my whole childhood
hanging out in the cul-de-sac on the
south side
what a great place and then I think like
yeah because like South Mountain
Community College is right there seven
the Baseline it's changed right oh my
God we're like a Target and all kinds of
[__] over there is a white man living in
the house I grew up in I was so confused
for people who don't know the south side
of Phoenix was kind of like the
African-American American side of town
yes right yes yes it's like a very
you know different there's a difference
there was a Target which was like okay
cool with that right awesome and then
now there was like a Whole Foods and
[__] when I went back it was so confused
and then everybody moved to Levine they
bought houses in Levine yeah they were
like okay we could get a house for a
hundred and ten thousand dollars in this
suburb on the south side yeah so crazy
but
yeah I love it yeah so when did you make
the move to Los Angeles to pursue your
hopes and dreams I was young I was 16 I
moved on my own with my 18 year old best
friend wow so did you finish school
no I technically did so technically I
had a GED okay and I graduated do you
have a GED and a diploma yes and special
I was on the field for the
and I was on the field with my with the
classmates from the high school that I
went to before I dropped out when I was
going to online school
I've never met anybody with both yeah
it's pretty uh that's that's extra like
I got the GED and I got the diploma
because why not get both
gotta all the way what school did you go
to were you like did you walked out on
the field on not the online school
because so I went to school in ahwatuki
okay by two years that I did High School
all by two kids mountain Point yeah
where'd you go Mountain Point yeah yeah
I used to date a girl who went to
Mountain point I'm sorry she went to
evit
did you know anybody who went to evit at
the time you heard it even though East
Valley Institute of Technology like kids
oh kids would go there like for their
electives no that's where I went to
school for radio broadcasting in Mesa
it's on Main and uh home school okay
Mesa so yeah East Valley Children's
Theater I was in that I don't know what
that is that sounds amazing yeah so
what's it like being like uh you know
listen there's some great talent in
Arizona I don't want to [__] on Arizona
but you're kind of like the only like
super [__] lit person from Phoenix
right now thank you it's so crazy like I
feel
first of all I feel kind of like
isolated and like almost like I have to
prove myself because people don't know
nothing about Phoenix right and they
don't know anything about Arizona so
everyone just assumes like everybody's
white everybody's Trump supporters which
there is a lot of that there's a there
is a lot of that also Arizona went Biden
last election somehow yeah
um but you know there's also a lot of us
so yeah it's a very like wild place
because like it is where everyone goes
to retire there is a lot of old white
folks but it's also like where it goes
down everyone's strapped the [__]
cartels running [__] it's a crazy Place
yeah there's gangs there's it's a
[__] Arizona is a wild place for sure
it's just it's kind of like Florida like
Florida is a [__] up place but it's
also a place rich people go to die no
it's literally the desert version of
Florida it is the desert version of
Florida yeah for sure do you feel like
Mexican or uh La is lacking a Filibertos
style option of food that's open 24
hours a day that is so funny you said
that because that was like when I went
to Arizona that was like one of the
first places I wanted to go I just feel
like how are we in LA and I can't get a
burrito at any time of the night I mean
like you're if you're in Arizona you can
go to Philly's at 6 30 in the morning
you can go at 3 A.M you can go out here
this taco trucks close at two like I
don't know where else you're supposed to
[__] go to get food except McDonald's
and we're in La the city that's not
supposed to sleep yeah I'm not trying to
get McDonald's either terrible 24-hour
food options in Los Angeles we can go to
Christine's mom's house Christine's
mom's house in the valley in the 818
. yeah I'm like you know Philly's is not
the greatest in Mexican food but it's
there it's there it's it's Dependable
you know you can go get a California
Burrito anytime of the night after the
club you might be shit-faced go to
Phillies or Robertos or Romeros or
juliobertos or any type of Berto
it's a lot of birthdays out there there
is uh so how did you initially like okay
you're 16 years old you decided to move
to LA were you already kind of like
garnering up like a buzz or did you just
come out here like I'm gonna [__] it I'm
gonna just leave home and go chase this
[__]
so it started off with
my mom putting me in I mean first of all
I was saying dancing acting my whole
life it was like East Valley Children's
Theater and like Valley youth theater
and doing musical theater doing pageants
all the [__] okay my mom really
sacrificed a lot right and my stepdad
was like I saw for me to do that so
really grateful for that so I started
with that since I was like three years
old okay and then
was
put in by my mom a competition a single
competition online okay through Kidz Bop
oh they were doing like a separate thing
called Kid star USA okay shout out to
the Kidz Bop albums
um so they were doing that I ended up
winning the competition my mom didn't
tell me until I was in like top five
that I was even in the competition right
she's like I submitted you you had no
idea exactly by the way your top five
you might it might your life might
change you might exactly yeah
um and the prize was to win a record
deal okay
um and so
I was I think I was a yeah I was a
freshman by the time I had won and they
came to my school and did this whole
like assembly thing wow it was like
really extra as [__] but it was so cool
um so that then I went to New York and
signed with my first record deal
and then that's when I started kind of
going back and forth between Phoenix and
La okay a lot and then there was times
where I was like living in La pretty
much for like a month and then I would
go back home and just like come on my
own right
um
and then I
was officially here when I was 16.
and then I got dropped when I was 17.
from the Kidz Bop first label well I was
touring with Kidz Bop for a little bit
okay okay what's that wait wait wait
what's the tour with kids Bob who's
who's it goes off it's crazy is it just
a bunch of people's like a bunch of
children on stage singing like in the
club yeah like five kids just like gosh
it's your birthday yeah we're gonna
party like it's your birthday and you're
on stage doing all the Renditions
dancing what's the most ridiculous what
was the most inappropriate Kids Bop song
because some of the songs you're like
how did they how did that make it to a
Kidz Bop compilation I think um one of
the ones that we perform well okay we
performed what's that Macklemore song
were you talking about being in the same
love thrips oh thrift shops that was
called Thrift Shop I'm like he's talking
about being another Shop thrift shop we
did that one and it's like you know
there's a lot of like rapping in it so
we had to change a lot of words so they
were not appropriate for kids right so
that was interesting the things that we
changed it to were really funny and then
um Locked Out of Heaven that was also a
really
Bruno Mars yeah yeah Bruno Mars if you
listen his lyrics sometimes you're like
oh yeah it's almost like when you listen
to the weekend [__] like you really
listen and you're like
oh the weekend might have a drug problem
I love that though the weekend's my
favorite probably my favorite like I
mean I just love I don't know if I
listen to anyone more than the weekend
I love the weekend he's amazing did you
see him at a sofa no but she did it was
[__] fire really I went the night
before he didn't perform because he
would you know he came out on stage and
like apologized to everybody because his
voice wasn't you know oh no which
actually liked because most people would
have just pushed through but he was like
nah I gotta do this the right way
we're in LA but he's amazing damn wait
did he come in like he spins yeah he
redid it like a few I think it was like
a month and a half or two later and then
it's on HBO now I just watched it
tripping on shrooms oh good for you yeah
should I do that you wanna eat shrooms
right now
um
I think Christine what about his advice
again okay I just gotta ask because they
do have them
we have the raw we have the gummies you
just let me know me and uh Ray shrimmer
were Truman hard during our interview
really yes like things are getting real
realistic yes you enjoy uh psilocybin I
really enjoy it and I don't do nothing I
don't drink good I don't smoke weed I
don't do nothing but you'll you'll
partake in I just said nothing but
mushrooms shrooms are great they're
amazing yeah they're literally like
medicine I have people who uh like a
couple of my friends they'll microdose
before they work out because it gives
them like a little more focus a little
more energy and like a little lift yeah
ah I heard that have you ever been a DMT
no I want to try it I'm scared I don't I
don't think I would do it why not
because I'm bipolar as [__] it might get
rid of that I'm not well the mushrooms
do that for me I'm good I'm good with
that maybe one day or Ayahuasca like
Aaron Rodgers I do want to do Ayahuasca
though I actually do I heard that or
change it that's like 30 years ago
Chelsea Handler do it on her show how
was that it was so interesting like she
was like crying at the end and [__]
talking I have a friend who changed
their whole life her sister and like it
just changes everything I mean mushrooms
did that for me too the first time I how
much did you eat though did you eat a
lot well I we made it in tea oh so
that's so you it was good because it was
like I could just slowly get into it and
take more and more and I didn't know
what to expect that's what I loved
belly's like that belly only likes it in
tea he's like big shroom guy but he
drinks it I don't know if I could drink
it
there's like no escaping if you drink it
I feel like
you actually can
well from what I was told but like if
you gotta I went to Amsterdam
and they like it's so different there
because they it's like it's like yeah
it's just how it is it's like a
dispensary but it's like New York City
now different I've been in New York
recently you just go to the liquor store
like a literally the corner store in New
York City they got shrooms right behind
the counter it's [__] in New York
City you could buy a blunt an eighth and
some mushrooms all at the bodega now
well we'll be there why it's the Wild
Wild West right now so you'll see just
anywhere where they got like a smoke
shop just walk in they right behind the
counter this is wow it's on display
that's good yeah in Amsterdam they said
that I love it because they like
actually educate you right and [__] and
like they'll give you like a slip and
like tell you exactly how to do it but
they were saying if you start to feel
too high or you're like not feeling good
just drink juice as soon as you eat
something with like a high amount of
sugar in it it will start bringing down
your high I'd rather eat too much
shrooms than eat too much weed
because eating too much wheat is
terrible
it's the worst [__] ever you've ever had
like a like a bad edible experience the
worst I've never had that but I've I've
literally
I can't even do CBD that's how bad it is
well I don't think CBD is a thing I
think it's like you know one of those
things where like mentally you think
it's supposed to help you out but it's
like it's a placebo effect it's like you
got a CBD massage my wife got a CBD
massage in Palm Springs this weekend so
what do you think that is what the [__]
are they gonna do they're gonna rub CBD
on you here's a blunt smoke it
I mean yeah it's not good for you so you
get paranoid no I had like a full-on
episode like it was bad so you're out on
the 420 on THC it's not for you no
that's good none of that I'll celebrate
with mushrooms shrooms are amazing uh
you have a lot of tattoos yeah I do can
we explain a few of the more notable
ones that you would feel like you know
because you got you got a lot and
they're very like
there's some other father there looks to
be a church there
is that a hookah or is that a genie lamp
perfume okay it's a perfume bottle yeah
but I like that people are like a
jellyfish a jellyfish is my favorite
animal this is there's a type of
jellyfish I think it's called The
Eternal jellyfish why do you uh love
them so much because it's the only
animal I mean they're just cool like
they don't have brains and they're
living like they're literally just like
floating around but they're alive and
like they're not really conscious like
it's I just saw one for the first time
yeah but this eternal jellyfish lit it
can live forever it's the only animal
that lives forever oh [__] so once it's
like it I think it's something like if
if
um
if it gets like
feels a threat or something happening it
just starts at the life cycle all the
way over and goes back to being a polyp
and then we'll start that's wild every
isn't that crazy have you ever been to
Rocky Point no I was in Rocky Point last
summer and I was surrounded by jellyfish
and I cried like a [__]
I was afraid I was like my [__] well
I'm gonna have to get pissed on did you
get stuck I didn't I was afraid I was
like someone's crying like a [__] and
you didn't they were everywhere
I just all of a sudden I looked around
and I was like is that a plastic oh [__]
it's a [__] it's like seven jellyfish
I wasn't actually crying but I really
was like I'm done
I started panicking I know that feeling
though I was in Australia one time I was
like some dude's gonna have to pee on me
like I don't even know the guy no no no
no no okay no yeah I'm okay never now
shout out to R Kelly but I'll pass you
can't knock it to you hard pass hard
pass on the stranger Pete
um okay so what else do we have here
what is the fruit on your shoulder is
that a fruit this thing right here right
here
this yeah oh this is um uh salvoro Dali
he has a not a fruit oh Bali it's an egg
actually so he has a uh he actually has
a Art Museum in St Petersburg Florida
where I used to live really the Bali
museum is there that's dope yeah yeah so
it's an egg with a flower coming out of
it yeah you got some Vibes what is well
who's Nancy that's my grandma shout out
to Grandma yeah gotta pay homage to
grams do you like to play craps is that
why you have dice no I have dice because
I've been rolling a dice since 97 it's a
fixed time I like that are you were you
born in 87
wow when were you born 87.
yeah I got a decade I remember 97. do
you do you really for sure what's what
is like the most vivid memory you have
from 97 walking around Christown Mall
without my parents
do you have any parents what happened
because I was a bad kid who would like
my all my friends are older so I'd be
like 10 years old running around on the
red line in Phoenix [__] going to
Metro Center in the Christown Mall
watching my friends steal stuff oh my
God yeah Valley Metro good place yeah
yeah uh so for you uh it's been a long
time since you put out music
pre-pandemic even yeah what's been going
on
um I've just honestly
oh god I've been writing this whole time
album's ready to come out now I think
there's just been a lot of uh
obstacles okay that have come up that
I've had to kind of maneuver around to
make it to this point so I'm just I've
just been trying to
like personal stuff business stuff both
and a lot of times they are both yeah
they can be both I'm an artist so like
my work is me so everything I take
everything really personally which is
also like kind of bad I need to work on
like separating it a little bit more
right but um but yeah everything is like
super personal to me so pretty much
everything that has to do with work is
like so the album is called grudges
correct yeah white grudges
I hold a grudge very easily it's hard
for me to if you're from the south side
I get it yeah it's really it's really
hard for me to just be like okay because
also like loyalty is everything to me so
like if I'm and I'm I really try to be
like the best friend that I can to
people I'm just like a good person so if
I'm being
what I think is an amazing friend to you
and you think I'm gonna be an amazing
friend to you and you're like
just [__] living in it and then you
do something to [__] me over it just
shows me what kind of person you are
because I don't I don't change like
coming into no situation so it's like
I'm always gonna be myself I'm always
going to be open have you probably dealt
with a lot of that being in LA because
the music industry is full of weirdos
which is so shitty to say because I feel
like a lot of times it's like I wanted
to say like oh it just gets a bad rap or
like I really like that it's probably a
little worse truth it is the truth most
people who are like your Associates or
friends here are only that as long as
they see the benefits coming down the
pipeline or it's like trust me I know
yeah it's crazy 100 everybody's kind of
offer themselves but I have met a few a
few real ones a few ruins for sure
that's for sure a few granted people is
your 18 year old best friend from
Phoenix who you moved out here with
still around she's not here but she's
gonna move back oh what's she doing
she actually moved
South Mountain too which she didn't live
there so she moved to South Phoenix she
moved to South Phoenix voluntarily yeah
yeah well her mom lives there so she
like went oh she's coming back but she
likes it because like she hikes every
day and you know it's so fresh
she's a hug
it's truly hot yeah remember that heat
wave bruh it felt like Phoenix for like
two months people don't understand the
heat of Phoenix yeah you'll get in the
car and get a third degree burn on from
your [__] seat literally literally
it's so crazy like when I I can't when I
go back I just I'm so spoiled here now
as a kid are you like listening to MC
Magic and NB Ridaz or you know who they
are though like you know who MC Magic is
as a kid I mean it's more like you know
the Latin side of things but you weren't
an MC Magic fan just your friend over
there from there yeah she's yeah
that's like all she listens all I
listened to was little Rob Amanda Perez
and NB Ridaz no but it's because my so
the the way that I
the only way I know my culture and have
been informed is from my surroundings
growing up
my grandpa was deported when before my
mom was born so I never got to know the
Mexican side of my family we're like
finding them on DNA ancestry which is
crazy like getting in contact with like
cousins and uncles and [__] it's wild so
I'm trying to find her dad because we
don't even know like where he is or like
we're guessing who he is right
um but yeah it's been like a whole so
you're Mexican and what black okay yeah
so you like the whole Mexican Vibe going
on in Phoenix just kind of passed you
like there was like the low rider shows
that were crazy and like yeah what yes
did you ever go to the swap meet like on
like 40th Street yeah in Washington yeah
that's where I got my name I was there
selling mixtapes and DVDs and fake
purses and fake Jordans yes I almost got
arrested like 11 times I've been banned
from the swap meet by the airport like
at least 10 times they told me to never
come back so I would just book my spot
under a different name every time
and then I'd pay the guys to like let me
know when the security was walking
around and I'd just walk off how old
were you 16 17 18. had like a newborn
kid when I was 18. you're like I'm still
doing it today no I'm not I'm not I'm
not but
I still do get random WhatsApp messages
from like Chinese ladies who have [__]
for sale so they'll send me like a link
and be like new product available
and I'll be like damn they're
bootlegging iPods and and uh not iPods
the uh airpod like the airpods you know
those 300 big heavy duty yeah you can
get those counterfeit and they're
supposed to sound the same wow you get
anything counterfeit MAC makeup that was
a Vibe for a little bit slang in that
Mac you know what I'm saying
did you know where that was coming from
China yeah I was literally I would like
I would literally get on like MSN
Messenger with like a little Chinese
lady on webcam and she would show me
[__] and she'd be like wow and then send
it to you I'd be like show me the Larry
Fitzgerald jersey let me see the back
wow let me get 50 of those
that's crazy that's a great swap meet
great place
um okay so why is there so you got all
your Affairs in order all the stuff you
went through is finally kind of settled
and now we have the album yes oh yeah so
what I was gonna say was
the album also had a different name
before okay
it was called closure
and then as we added more songs and I
did more sessions and I was going
through more [__] in my life it just
didn't feel like I had closure on
nothing like it felt like oh okay I'm
just like literally talking [__] and I'm
talking about all the [__] that I'm
going through and there's no answer to
none of the things that I'm putting out
there so it's grudges and not closer so
the new song with LMA it seemed did
someone play you is that what happened
did
I mean people always play we just talked
about this we just talked about how like
I'm saying were you like in it because
because at first of all I I love the
song because it's definitely like a
relatable song because a lot of people
try to act like they're not jealous
people but you know you know like you're
like oh drop all your [__] or don't
drop all your [__] but drop off you
drop all the [__] yeah is that
something you actually went through
yeah so I've had that feeling so I
the thing about me is like I'm one of
those people that says I'm not a jealous
person where every by the way every
woman ever is that no no no but no
they're all I'm not jealous who the [__]
is this [__] liking your photos no you
can ask Christine that's my best friend
and my manager she's literally with me
every single day because she has to be
but you would choose
um but literally I'm not jealous the
only thing that I'm I get jealous about
which is so valid okay
is Instagram which is okay liking other
people's photos like other [__] what
kind of photos
I'm just asking I just have to ask like
okay if it's like a girl who's like bent
over and says Lincoln bio
sure I'd be that's a problem but it's
like like girls that like you don't even
know like you don't even be knowing them
and they're like you know I I love a
girl in the Bikini pic I have a bikini
pic we all do it it's great right but if
my partner is liking that person's
pictures you don't even know her first
of all second of all she's not looking
out for you right she doesn't give a
[__] if you're liking her pictures so
that's that's the Line in the Sand for
you yes it's just like why because I'm
okay with like you looking at the
picture enjoying it and then scrolling
like I know we all
but don't double tap don't double tap
why why do you have to go the extra mile
because you want attention so what do
you want the attention yeah what do you
want what do you want that person you
like them yeah that's where my issue
what if they're just following the
person is that a problem
no
hmm no that's what I'm saying like I I
understand that we're attracted to
people right like do you follow like I'm
I'm trying to figure out what the female
equation or uh equivalent is to you know
guys will follow IG thoughts right are
there dude versions of that that I'm
just not hip to like are there guys with
like 12 like 12 packs I don't even think
that's real that'd be definitely
surgical if that's a thing I'm sure
there is but I don't want to see it I'd
be following the Instagram girls because
their women are just so much more
beautiful I agree so you'll follow the
IG women as well yeah okay so yeah okay
don't be tapping don't don't double tap
don't do it like just don't do it why
especially because it's like for nothing
right you're not you're not gonna get
that attention you're seeking you're
hoping that you get yeah yeah yeah and
then you look crazy because if like one
of your mutual friends is like sees that
they're liking their shoes your man is
over here double tapping Rosa acosta's
[__] ass [__] exactly and my worst
fear like I hate other people knowing
things about me that I don't know
and that's like the worst part you don't
want to feel you don't want to feel like
you're getting like yeah not hear you I
don't want to look like an idiot right
you know like I don't want other people
knowing [__] before me that was like the
most that was the worst part about being
cheated on the one time I was cheated on
I was like the most [__] up part was
that everyone knew except except you so
it was like they were like the friends
knew because it's I feel like it's like
a probably a different situation if like
your man is on vacation in Miami and he
hooks up with a stranger he's never
gonna see again sure you should hate
that and you should leave him for that
but it's not like if like this it's like
a thing a known thing yeah and
everyone's lying to your face and like
you're like what the [__] like I'm just
boo boo the fool at this point yeah no
it was like it was so bad like my like
this guy and his best friend had a
threesome basically with this girl
that's kind of that's how I got cheated
on and then his friend that he did it
with asked me to pick him up from the
airport before I knew hmm
um yeah yeah I don't know man yeah trash
I don't know if I you know could
participate
in such activities would you if I'm not
sure partner cheated on you right
wood
it hurt you more if they did it because
they loved the person or if they did it
because it was just like a one night
thing but because they loved the person
that would hurt more I think so huh
what about you no that wouldn't hurt
more because you're like at least you
understand yeah it's like okay I can't
help that you love that person you had a
connection with that person at least
you're not wasting it you're like
there's some investment there and I hope
you live happily on your ass yeah take
this event but if it's like you're just
yo what up it's bootleg cab we gotta
stop the interview to tell you about our
folks at my bookie that's right so many
ways you can gamble with my bookie right
now man of course you got NBA playoffs
Western Conference Finals Eastern
Conference Finals they're set I love
Celtics versus Lakers in the finals all
right you can sign up at mybookie.ag
right now using that promo code bootleg
and get a very generous first deposit
bonus that's right and they just got the
craziest like revamp of the online
casino it's like a Las Vegas experience
if you play cards Blackjack roulette uh
you shoot dice whatever it is they have
like live dealers handling it for you
wherever you're at you could be at the
airport and be playing [__] roulette
on your phone it's amazing mybookie.ag
sign up with that promo code
leg right now you can bet on Sports you
could do slots you could do Blackjack
craps whatever you're into mybookie.ag
promo code bootleg for that first
deposit bonus and it is a generous one
also got to give a shout out to our
family at King Palms shout out to King
Palm man if you only know about King
Palms you're our new sponsor on the
bootleg kept podcast and they got such a
great product the best thing about King
Palms is it's all organic man no tobacco
in these wraps they're straight Leafs
and the best thing uh about them is they
got this product
they're flavor terpene tips all right
you stuff them with your with your
product
do we got one here oh we do got one here
we got one right here we got one right
here all right
you stuff this with your uh premium
cannabis from Hardy in Las Vegas
all right you smoke up pinch that tip
you're gonna get a burst of flavor yeah
this is the energy drink flavor we got
Peach pineapple we got watermelon wave
also don't forget the goddamn
blue grapes you know what I mean and
also this is a tobacco-free wrap it's
totally organic it's literally a leaf
let me show you what I mean
that is just a big ass Leaf guys all
right so what you could do is go to
kingpom.com weeds flying everywhere
kingpom.com promo code bootleg and uh
you can get 50 off of whatever you order
at kingpom.com and don't forget to check
them out because they're everywhere your
local smoke shop your local liquor store
7-Eleven smoke the King Palm all right
it's organic it ain't like all that
other [__] y'all be [__] stuffing
in your lungs man all right shout out to
kingpong kingpom.com promo code bootleg
right now and it's actually promo code
bootleg Kev promo code bootleg Kev not
bootleg bootleg cab kingpom.com half off
everything let's get back to the
interview by the way you just threw a
whole thing away for like a stupid and
also in the same room as another naked
dude like I couldn't perform why are you
doing that I'd be like bro why why do
you gotta like what's up with the gang
bang situation that shit's wild people
love that do they yes I just don't get
it I mean I understand being with two
girls but my thing is is like I don't
want to look across and see my homie in
his bag and be like
hey hey bro you're [__] that [__] up
can I jump in that's the thing though
okay this is this is what I want to talk
about I I hear you
what I want to talk about is from the
female perspective because yes there's
that whole male situation of like
looking back and forth at your friends
yeah and like you probably you're not
interested in men right right so like
you probably wouldn't like that but then
there's a girl there let's not forget
about the woman so I think also like
porn [__] us up for sure porn I can
agree with you that completely [__]
people up it has ruined when it comes to
women and objectifying women there's
great porn out there terrible
expectations PornHub
standard [__] also why is everything
step that's disgusting can we just talk
about that first of all second of all
there is a woman that is enjoying that
as well I feel like it's like we just
kind of throw like so I can't judge that
right because I I feel like I don't know
what like whatever you're in okay I'll
never judge somebody for being like if
your thing is I like to [__] girls with
my boy
it's a Bonnie I don't care like cool
that's for you bro I don't judge it just
like I can't judge the woman who's in
the middle of the Eiffel Tower I can't
judge it she's obviously having an
amazing time with that being said you
said there's great porn out there which
category
I mean are we talking about like this
tasteful HBO like 2 am skinnamax like
where it's like I never seen that oh
okay yeah I've never seen that but
there's more I think the tasteful stuff
is just where you're seeing pleasure
from both people right not just one
straight man right right like that's
like
I just think back in the day when I was
a kid there was like real acting
involved you know there was like I hate
that there was like a Pirates of the
Caribbean remember that one the Pirates
of the Caribbean one
the most important and it was the most
successful it was like right when the
first Pirates of the Caribbean came out
like Jenna Jameson was in it I was like
damn there's like real production now
it's like I'm I'm it's like a lot of
demeaning [__] for sure I just can't
like yeah once there's a I need like
real [__] like I want it to look like
people are actually there having a great
time I don't need acting right yeah I
mean I feel like I don't need the
storyline yeah I can make up my own
storyline this is true I mean the
storyline's very very 70s 80s like yo I
heard you guys have a leak
exactly the Plumber's at the door
exactly my husband's away
I'm stuck yeah yeah crazy uh okay so you
have obviously you have LMA on the
project you guys have a dope record out
right now uh anybody else you can share
with us
Christine said yes so
MC Magic's on the album
um
we have Khalid oh I like that yeah it's
a great voice also that's someone in the
industry that's a really [__] cool
person and he's from somewhere random
too isn't he from Texas yeah he is so
down to earth he is like the most one of
the most grounded people I've met in
this entire year he seems like a nice
guy he is so [__] sweet I've never
met him but I saw him perform once uh
when it was like his first headlining
tour it was for like four or 500 people
and his voice is just going at the Roxy
it was in Phoenix it was that uh it was
Act
it was way before that it was a
clubhouse in Mesa it's for like 400
people small venue very small wow like a
hole in the wall like there's like a
meth lab like six feet away yeah I lived
in Mesa for a little bit when I was
younger I'm sorry that's right I went to
high school she was in a mobile home
mobile home of course it was yeah it was
nice was it like super East Mesa like
like East not super East no so you lived
in a trailer park I was no they were all
mobile homes but it was like it was like
a you know houses could have been built
there but they were all mobile homes
being as you're from Arizona and lived
in a trailer park yeah
hahaha
did you run into a lot of Juggalos
growing up like Insane Clown Posse fans
are you aware of who these people are no
okay okay I got it such a big thing in
Arizona no please share there's a group
called the Insane Clown Posse okay uh
they make some of the historically
terrible music that's ever been recorded
uh they're a rock group from Detroit
they are guys grown men who dress like
clowns
they they really were kind of like
revolutionary on the independent circuit
because they they had a lot of big merch
situations like if you were dispensers
you buy there it was there yes no way
but so they have uh uh their fans are
called Juggalos
and they
uh they're the FBI
classify them as a gang
right in like early 2000s what the [__]
is Arizona and so now there's like a
bunch of grown ass like 45 year old like
high school teachers with like hatchet
man tattoos on their body like it's like
they're a little let me see I'm gonna
show you their show me because you might
have seen you might have seen this maybe
your ex-boyfriend who cheated on you
with this friend has one of these
tattoos maybe and you were like you
didn't know you didn't know you were
dating a juggalo crazy
so you've never seen this on someone's
skin in Arizona
or on a like car somewhere oh yeah that
looks crazy so this is yeah it's the
hatchet man but I just you said you
lived in a trailer I look like Keith
Herring I don't even know who that is
like it looks like their own take
Keith Herring you don't know who Keith
hearing is he's an artist he does
literally [__] like that oh I don't have
my phone to pull it up yeah so they so
they have a concert every year still to
this day called the Gathering of the
Juggalos and it's in the middle of Ohio
on private land and they bring like it's
like the White Trash Circus every year
but there's tons of rappers who do it
like I got a lot of friends who perform
should I go perform there no oh you
should go though because I heard it's a
good time but they have a drug Bridge so
there's like a bridge where you could go
by heroin and meth what all kinds of
[__] and there's a gang bang tent
there's a TP and there's like some dirty
foot white chick in there just getting
railed by all these meth addicts like
it's crazy
the Gathering of the Juggalos there's
like documentaries vices done
documentary you should look it up on
YouTube Just dive into the Insane Clown
Posse Juggalo rabbit hole and thank me
later
I'm so sad I haven't been there yet they
did you ever watch Workaholics on Comedy
Central yeah okay they did a whole
episode really from the Gathering of the
Juggalos oh I didn't watch it like that
but that sounds great yes yeah I just
didn't know you were like I lived in a
trailer park in Mesa yeah but I was so
young shout out to Mesa but there was uh
the Baseline killer was found right
across the street so like I lived like
this is like the street and this is the
street I lived in this house and the
the stopping point like as far as me and
my brother could go to like ride our
bikes and like Scooters or whatever was
this apartment complex and that's the
apartment complex that the Baseline
killer lived in so we were actually
trying like my mom was trying to keep us
safe and then there's a serial killer
well there was like the Baseline killer
and do you remember like the dudes who
were rolling around just shooting people
yes shooting people and that was on
Baseline too no that was in Mesa yeah
yeah they found the guys in Mesa yeah it
was two guys really [__] white dudes
send me that documentary and they were
just riding around Arizona just shooting
strangers it was [__] spooky like
you'd be like [__] I can't walk anywhere
yeah yeah it was a wild time man yeah
wild time okay so uh khalid's on the
album yes wow whoa this is like wow MC
Magic's on the album insane you narrate
like my brain okay this conversation is
how my brain goes I love it
um colleagues on the album Bryson
tiller's on the album
that is a really great song okay single
I can't wait for you to hear it is it
single it's a focus yeah all right they
might be a little bit of focused on it
were you guys in the studio together
no actually he was sick at the time but
it sounded great I mean we talked about
it you're like I recorded this verse
it's kind of a Vibe but he did come to
the studio and listen to it but he likes
to record like alone yeah he's like a
very I feel like he'd be the kind of guy
be like I want to record this at home in
my basement away from everybody no he's
very like he likes to do [__] on his own
he's like a very he's an artist in that
way I feel like you and LMA are making
like amazing traditional like dope r b
music which I feel like is kind of
missing in terms of like I feel like a
lot of the new r b [__] is cool but it's
also like a lot of these R B singers
want to be rappers low-key
and vice versa a lot of rappers want to
be R B singers now
it's like you did a lot of guys are
singers more than the rappers at this
point in time like do you feel like the
first person that we started talking
about that with
was Drake yeah but Drake's you know
Drake's Drake's in a unicorn he's kind
of a one-of-one he's I I feel like Drake
gets a pass he could do whatever if he
made a country album tomorrow it would
make sense I'd be like yeah I get it
like sure you know like of course
Drake's done afrobeats he's done
everything like country would not be you
know him and Kane Brown doing a Best of
Both Worlds album is not a something I
would do
surprised by at this point but I do feel
like you know that you feel like you're
kind of
a part of like oh except I told him I
made this I'm like yeah when I listen to
ulma like this [__] is like it just
reminds me of dope [__] like when I was
a kid listening to r b like do you feel
like you're kind of keeping that alive a
little bit
I feel like uh I just
do what feels right and I think we're
all inspired by something informed by
something and I love early 2000s r b and
that is my [__] so I think naturally I
would write songs and sing like I what
were you listening to when you were a
kid like what's the early 2000s [__]
that you were just loving like I love
Neo Usher Mariah I love Usher
yeah I didn't like when I just didn't
like when Neo started doing EDM music
that's so crazy I literally was just
talking about the time that everyone
switched from RMB to EDM oh it was him
and then Chris Brown was doing forever
and as everybody was still collaborating
with Pitbull and LMFAO and [__] Jesus
Christ the Dark Ages is what I call it
I was doing radio in Vegas and you
couldn't go to any [__] like none of
the clubs were playing anything but
[__] 128 bpms all the R B singers
stop making r b
so the best thing even Usher had like oh
my God no
we went to his show in Vegas we went to
the show in Vegas and he it was so
incredible and he started singing that
song and then he literally stopped at
one point he's like all right now we're
gonna go back to this [__] you guys
actually want to hear
I loved it it was so good shout out to
Trey songs who never folded yeah by the
way also not shout out to him for a lot
of the other [__] that's out there but
during that era he kept making r b music
let's shout at him shout at him yeah
shout at Trey songs um but no there was
a lot of um I do feel like you know it's
just dope because there is r b that
exists but for whatever reason you know
that's why I think it's dope there's
like you know certain radio shows out
there um selection who've like
highlighted kind of some of the dope
Army that's out there it's kind of like
underground kind of like it's kind of
like a new underground rap if you like
know some like real dope r b [__] like
you know what I mean like but I think
it's dope to see someone like yourself
making like just good old vintage [__] I
remember as a kid RMB thank you yeah I
love that yeah I've always just like
loved the good hook for sure I love a
good hook I I'm like I also started with
poetry too so like I love having like a
thesis and then just like Bill building
off of that and making everything like
super intricate but super specific to
that one thing and I also was writing
for a long time in LA for other people
or just like random sessions you were
kind of helping with the with other
people's [__] and I learned yes and I
learned from I was in sessions with pop
writers too because the label the first
level I was with didn't know what the
[__] to do with me so they were just
like let's just put her in with random
people so I was in a lot of Pop sessions
too and like I actually learned what the
structure of a song is from pop people
and would learn like just different
techniques that that I wouldn't have
learned
I wouldn't have learned in other spaces
I don't think for you because a lot of
people nowadays they don't necessarily
write as much as they do the melody and
then fill in the lyrics later are you
pretty intentional with like putting pen
to paper or sometimes I am it depends on
where I'm at in my life to be honest
like if I'm at home it's pen and paper
for sure like if you have an idea You're
Gonna Want to write it down yeah drop
some lyrics down if I'm well
I don't be on my phone when I'm driving
but you know if I well if you have a
test Siri wants to right if Siri wants
to help me out
then I'll tell Siri like write this down
I have an idea exactly like Hey Siri I'm
thinking about getting a Tesla just so I
can let it drive me while I do stuff on
my phone yeah I know people like that
yeah I don't know if that's a great idea
I don't think it is but it's an idea
I just I literally just ordered a Tesla
like uh maybe two weeks ago I haven't
decided to go through with it what kind
the model X plaid
it's like really the flat is like the
really fancy one or the fastest one but
it's the SUV so if you get a car it's
over 6 000 pounds you can ride a whole
thing off in year one little tax tax
loophole uh albums coming out in June
yeah what's today June 16th are you
nervous for like people to hear from you
it's been a while like I gotta I can
only imagine like
the level of vulnerability you put into
your music already has been at a high
level so to come back after it's been
four years it's been three yeah three
years so are you like a little nervous
to like kind of get back into the mix
it's so weird because
when we're releasing song like songs
from the album from the upcoming album I
I'm just like kind of numb to be honest
but like in like a
shocking way like I'm shocked I'm just
like oh my God it's actually here like
we're actually releasing these songs
because it's been so long but also
because I feel like this album is like
Kiki really changed my life and I feel
like this album is also going to change
my life so like to see it actually
coming out and like everything coming to
fruition and like it's in front of me
it's like so insane to watch
um so to think that the whole album is
coming
I like I can't even get there yet in my
mind how many songs
17. 17. that's a [__] full body of
work I have to it's been three years but
I'm really excited like I'm I'm like I'm
definitely super nervous because it's
been so long you know sophomore album is
always like the scariest one to put out
for sure there's so much pressure for
sure because you either have to make it
as good as the first one or better it's
tough and you don't know what the people
want right you just gotta do what you
want you just gotta do you keep it
moving just keep it moving you just
gotta push through it because a lot of a
sophomore album is it's always like
traditionally the album that like
a few very few people have gotten away
with like putting out a crazy sophomore
album like I feel like Kanye did it with
late registration you know there's like
a few guys but like it's all because if
you put out a first album that's like a
classic or like your fans just [__]
love they're always gonna go back
and like hold it up but it wasn't
Illmatic shout out to NAS but you know
I'm excited so uh for you uh is there
gonna be any touring yeah our solo
you're gonna hop on a tour with someone
else
I'm going solo okay so a little solo
headline run yeah are you bringing
anybody on the road with you don't know
yet don't know yet are you sure you got
to bring somebody right yeah
I don't know who it is how many videos
have you shot how many are in a can are
you gonna wait and see how the songs
perform uh we're shooting them we're
shooting visuals or we have visuals
we're just getting creative but we're
shooting we've been shooting visuals for
the last like
I don't know a couple months it's just
been kind of like slow
um but we have irresponsible
we have a deeper visual coming
do you have like pretty creative control
over that [__] because I feel like
you're you know pretty passionate
creative you know or do you let the
director just handle it no so I actually
like for a long time did not feel
comfortable
sharing my ideas or
taking the reins like I just was so
scared and like I just always felt like
I'm not a visual
I'm not a visually artistic person like
I I don't have I can't draw for [__] you
won't understand nothing with my
handwriting like I'm just I visually I
just can't do it right so I never felt
confident in my ideas when it came to
visuals and
lately I have been putting I I will like
come up with an idea and then just say
it and have the confidence to say it and
then
everybody just agrees and I'm like okay
cool let's do it but I still am like I
don't know if it's gonna be good and
then when I see other people liking it
it validates me so then it makes me want
to take the reins more and less dope
I've been I've become
the best some of the best compliments
that I've received have been when I've
had the most creative control oh that's
dope yeah a little validation yeah
gotta stop the interview real quick to
tell you about our family at Blue chew
baby that's right it's getting hot
outside you know what that means fellas
you're about to go get that dick wet you
know what I'm saying it might as well be
really hard it might as well be as hard
as it could possibly be and with
Bluetooth you will achieve such hardness
all right it's seriously amazing uh and
the best part about Bluetooth is you can
find out if it works don't just take my
word for it they're going to give you a
month's supply for free go to
bluetooth.com use that promo code
bootleg get a month supply for free
bluetooth.com promo code bootleg now
it's the same active ingredient as
Viagra and Cialis minus the awkward
doctor appointment you do not have to go
see some old dude and tell them about
your erectile dysfunction issues in
person because that's a [__] awkward
conversation bruh all you got to do is
go to bluetooth.com right now use the
promo code bootleg they're going to get
you hooked up with a month of supply for
free you just got to pay five dollars in
shipping no awkward doctor's
appointments same active ingredient as
Viagra and Cialis plus they got the
Bluetooth mint it's a chewable it's
great tastes like mint it's also the
same active ingredient as Levitra so
summertime's coming fellas you don't
want to underperform make sure your dick
is rocked up baby all right go to
bluetooth.com use the promo code bootleg
hey man it works what do you want from
me it [__] works everyone should have
a little Bluetooth in case of an
emergency
you might have an emergency you need to
pop a blue Choo chew it it's a chewable
you know what I mean anyway also got a
shout out to our family at Odd Socks
don't forget go to oddsoxofficial.com
promo code bootleg save 20 off man they
got the underwear that they just dropped
uh last year that's amazing so not only
do you get the most comfortable socks in
the world but you can also get the most
comfortable withdrawals in the world all
the crazy licenses they gotta have baked
socks they just announced their Hasbro
collection which is crazy because that
means you're going to get Monopoly socks
Transformer socks Power Ranger socks so
much [__] going with Odd Socks plus they
got The Odd Socks Basics my favorite
this is what I wear every day I wear the
basics because they're the most
comfortable socks I've ever put on my
[__] feet so experience the most
comfortable socks in the world with me
oddsoxofficial.com promo code bootleg
save 20 off shout out to Odd Socks let's
get back to the interview uh I know that
you kind of like are working with the 10
Summers crew now I don't know if anybody
knows that but any mustard production on
the uh on the album
has he got his fingerprints on any of
the songs
uh
I'm on 10 Summers so did you get a beat
or two or four or seven
I'm just curious are we gonna hear a
mustard on the beat you're not gonna
hear a mustard song I feel like well I
feel like I love this album okay okay
but you have some in the in the can for
the next album we have
are you gonna be on his album
no okay
because I heard I heard you could call
him ask him I heard his album's really
good ask him hit him up yeah what's it
like because obviously he's somebody who
is a legend in the game is it cool to be
able to kind of go to him for advice and
It's So Dope it's such a nice guy he's
so he's so nice
um I think it's just cool that I have
someone so experienced and like
so talented successful and really kind
he's a kind dude for sure to be in my
corner you know he's really like all 10
Summers since before I was with them
when I was on the road with Ella like
they've always rolled for me and like
always been super super supportive of me
like mustard whenever he was in town
coming to Ella shows he always came out
to watch my set which is dope it's so
it's just like so amazing so uh it's I
mean it's pretty incredible to have him
yeah in my corner who are you a fan of
like who are you listening to right now
like somebody who like might be
inspiring you or that you're just a fan
of that you don't think people maybe are
getting given enough attention to maybe
Dustin Conrad for sure I love ombre too
she I'm baby is like that's doing its
thing right now which I love her
um Destin's music is like
I also like I can't separate the person
from their Artistry I can't yeah it
doesn't work for me and like those two
people are really really amazing people
and they make incredible great people
making great music yes so for you
certain artists can be ruined right
you know yeah because I personally I
love R Kelly's music but he's a
god-awful human being like I can't sit
there yeah and not see the images that
were on [__] surviving R Kelly and
listen to R Kelly like that's just like
right ew yeah and then you can
some people can do it I I I love I love
half on a baby way too much and When a
Woman's Fed Up by R Kelly I don't think
about all of that I just like the song I
like the song it's almost like you don't
even want to hear him say the word woman
that's fair period that's fair that's
like you know Kanye is my favorite
artist ever
so I'm I can I can you know enjoy his
music no matter what type of wildness
comes out of his mouth
I just feel like I don't have
I don't have people like projects from
people that I'm that attached to I do
where I can separate like if I found out
Nas was a serial killer it would not
affect me listening shut up if like we
found out Nas was the Baseline killer in
Phoenix I'd be like damn that's crazy
um you know what I'm gonna still bump
Illmatic I mean
yeah I think I think especially in
hip-hop if you start I was gonna say
this it could be right
if you like actually look if this person
is a good person or not you're not going
to be listening to much you might listen
to Common a lot yeah yeah 100 you're
gonna be bumping common and
The Roots
yeah but it's so that's so interesting I
do talk about that like how cancel
culture has become like such a thing and
like we cancel a lot of people for a
different [__] which some people do
deserve to be careful some people do
deserve [__] deserve to be canceled
but cancel culture in general is like
it's like it's like we've gotten rid of
like letting people make mistakes and
learn things exactly for sure some
things are unforgivable but yes we've
gotten we've I think we went too far
with it but also like if we're canceling
people for certain things
but then that same person is also
listening to music that's talking about
catching bodies and like all this I'm
like what what kind of line is that I
agree it's like a week it's selective
it's so it's selective it's very simple
it's whoever like the you know that the
I guess the narrative is behind to to be
mad at at the time yeah it's like well
if you want to be mad at somebody you
could be mad at [__] I don't know
whoever there's some weird actors out
there that you're watching and they're
marvelous weird actors the dude who's
starring in Flash is a he might be a
psychopath that guy's a wild boy have
you heard it really flash he like
stumbled into some like lady's house in
Hawaii and like wait flash is uh not the
TV show The no the movie that's about to
come out the DC yeah yeah uh yeah he's
he's crazy but I'm like whatever I want
to watch Flash like you know I don't
know why I don't know why that seems
like
huh I don't know why actually maybe
sorry my brain is like I'm contemplating
in my brain and my mouth is not moving
fast enough
I don't know why that and it is I'm not
saying it's not I don't know why that
it's harder to think about canceling
someone that's an actor
over a musician I think maybe you're
more passionate about music
you are a very empathetic person or
you're just really good at lying which
is great right right but like it's great
for your job but you really have to like
you have to separate that yeah like
there's no I mean unless you're like Jim
Carrey who like really gets into
character and he's like that person or
like Daniel Daniel Lewis is amazing he
was like my wife lived with Abraham
Lincoln or something for like like two
years and then there's like guys like uh
what was the name of the [__] show
Kevin Spacey star in as Frank Underwood
House of Cards House of Cards oh such a
good show and then we find out he's just
a creep
and then he stays in character on
YouTube and drops all these videos I'm
like this dude is a psychopath he's
psycho for sure they did they yanked him
out of it yeah but but no one watched it
after he wasn't in it it's like well
yeah he but he's he sucks you know do
you think that there's someone like
what if the person that
should have come out about
was not the main character like Kevin
Spacey was like say it's like a classic
movie like what's a movie that you loved
growing up like your favorite movie
The Big Lebowski okay is there someone
The Big Lebowski that's like should be
canceled
like ever probably not I mean maybe like
I don't know who I don't know the
characters in the big one okay it's Jeff
Bridges it's John Goodman Steve Buscemi
who's like kind of like a off character
like they're there but they're not like
there
uh you know who did who just tried to
get they just try to cancel uh didn't
they try to cancel [__] Larry David's
manager from Curb Your Enthusiasm Jeff
Garland
they try to cancel him for something why
I don't know but I was like I
I don't think he was doing you know
being a creepers Louis CK pulled his
dick out that's disgusting yeah she
should go there now did you hear about
what happened
Louis CK yeah so he asked someone who
worked for him if he could manually
stimulate himself in front of them right
okay they did not say no he did it it's
creepy it's weird
one of the funniest [__] of all
time but all I can't unsee that like I
can't I see yeah I can unsee it I'm like
I'll watch your stuff okay
has that happened to you before
where a man is no they had his little
dingling out and you walked in yeah and
it's happened to a lot of women before
this is true it happened to a lot of
women so that's I think that's where
it's like there are certain people where
I'm like you're just shit's not that
great like we talked about somebody
earlier I just don't give a [__] enough
to like like
care them like put the energy towards
yeah like Trey songs isn't great enough
for me to give like I'm like I'm done
like I'm out like I'm not I don't have
to listen to say I ever again I'm all
right you know but half of a baby by R
Kelly like I'm gonna listen to R Kelly
[__] yeah
and that's selective it is we're back to
selection 100 I am very selective see
that's also the thing though is I'm very
very very very very very sensitive to
other people's pain and like you have to
be and so when I'm seeing like [__] that
Trey Songz did and like Kiki's coming
out about it and trying to speak and
like no one gives a [__] about what
black women go through when it comes to
sexual assault and mental health and
[__] like that so like just seeing that
makes me wanna
oh no it's crazy it is crazy it's just
so and and and people over they'll like
Overlook it on purpose because they're
friends with you know yeah it's a whole
thing for sure
um yeah you know also there has to be a
line because if you looked into anything
like you literally couldn't live like
there was a time where like I wasn't I
wasn't exactly your phone is filled with
a bunch of [__] fibers from Congo I
mean Uber same thing there's like [__]
up [__] going on with Uber it was the
time where I wasn't going to Chick-fil-A
which I still actually haven't been to
Chick-fil-A in like years see me
I I feel you but I also love that
[__] Chick-fil-A no and you know
what's crazy is I was like you know I'm
gonna go eat that Christian chicken
exactly and I was like I'm not doing
that I'm taking a stand like that
chicken we're going right
[Applause]
said what I'd be getting that I've been
getting the [__] chicken I think in
like 2016 I only used Lyft because I
found out the Uber guy like donated to
Trump or something and then I realized
like how [__] ridiculous am I being
but Uber also owns Lyft now yeah but
like it was like before that happened
but I was like what am I really doing
here like I'm gonna wait you're not
gonna fight the system yeah like how
many like if I did that with everything
I'd be [__] would you literally just
be sitting in a dirt patch yeah I'd be
in [__] Skid Row you know like just
trying to figure it out like I I don't
need anything I'm just gonna sleep in my
tent I'm gonna live off sustainable
energy it could be
you don't know where the tent was made
houses made Jesus
everything is [__] humans are just
[__] up everything's [__] we just
gotta try to maneuver around and try our
best to be good people are you are you
uh veganish
vegan-ish yeah I'm flexitarian you love
animals
yeah I love animals me too I love
animals but I don't love them enough to
not more
selective selective I don't love like I
love animal like I have dogs you know
like I'm not gonna need a dog but like
I'll [__] up a cow for sure you know
okay so if you looked at a cow in its
face and they're beautiful they're cute
animals one of the fluffy ones with the
little horns and it's brown so cute you
can like hold it I'd have a pet cow for
sure at my house but then I'd eat his
seventh cousin do you but you wouldn't
eat the cow not if it was my pet cow no
if I had to I'd eat that [__]
for sure that's crazy there's some
psychological thing I have a Pomeranian
that if [__] went left and we were in
the middle of the Armageddon
lebowski's getting fried up my boy
oh my God that's so good anyway wow well
listen grudges is coming out
oh yeah well who's your yeah yeah what's
your Mount Rushmore of uh of r b
um that's really hard
that's really hard
what about you oh well my brain sorry go
ahead what about just right now
okay
Janae Janae
you know I was gonna say that you love
Janae I love Janae she's she's my
favorite artist so she's like your your
goat she is man incredible she's like a
[__] Fairy like she's just perfect
but she's real like that's what I love
about her yeah for sure so you love
janae's just taking all four spots Janae
is taking all four spots have you hung
out with her yet
oh my god do you want to know the story
sure
Okay so
uh we had like damned a couple times
okay and I was just like oh my God I
can't believe she's like responding like
that's crazy Janae Aiko is responding to
it yes
so then we both were performing at Soul
Bloom and I was also on mushrooms which
was crazy because three times that man
she had bubbles coming up at the end of
her set she was singing like a song
about life and death like I and I was
like freaking out about death at the
time too I was like obsessing over it
for months right so like that was just a
crazy moment for me anyway so we like
the show is over and we're like walking
through the backstage area to get to
where we needed to go and as we're
walking back all these people are like
crowded around and they're all like
and they're insecurities like go go go
and then I just hear Kiana
and I was like
yeah
and she was like you want to come and
take a picture and I was like
okay and then I started walking and the
Security's going crazy and I'm like
Janae I'm scared I'm on mushrooms
but that's like one of the most amazing
memories I'll ever have that's amazing
did you post the photo
I did actually yeah I did nice I gotta
go this is a horrible photo but I didn't
give a [__] is it still up up because I
want to see what you look like shroomed
out with Janae
I'll send you I'll send it to you there
it is well look uh the album comes out
June 16th 16 16th grudges new song out
with uh you have a couple new records
out right now yeah I love the record
with uh Ella Ellis visual are you naked
in the visualizer is that what's
happening there am I naked in the
visualizer I feel like it's like a
silhouette of uh just looks like a no no
no I have just like a really tight dress
on which is pretty much like one of
those like Band-Aids like those like
bandages it's basically a black bandage
all around my body it doesn't sound very
comfortable go check it out appreciate
you coming through thanks for having me
the Phoenix goat right here Keanu leday
stop boom
hey we gotta wrap up an interview
brought to you by hardean Las Vegas
appreciate y'all watching hey don't
forget when you go to Vegas you got to
go to Hardee man it's the craziest
dispensary you'll ever walk into it
smells like [__] heaven in there all
right get in that Uber when you hit Sin
City tell them take me to hardine
they're gonna take you you're gonna get
a wild selection of the just top top of
the line cannabis the best selection
you'll go uh uh be able to see in the US
Plus on top of that they got the crazy
gear they got the clothes they got the
bikinis they got a wonderful selection
of Bud tenders that are very good at
their job man they'll take care of you
tell them that bootleg have sent you the
bud tenders are Harding don't know what
that means they're gonna get you hooked
up right all right go follow them online
Harding underscore Las Vegas or just go
check out their website too man
hardinglasvegas.com and when you're in
Vegas pull up to Jardin or you're
playing yourself for real